not this whacking crap again this time
his comedian dave chappelle violently
attacked on stage in the middle of his
comedy set not funny
make some noise for hip-hop history
man lunging at the comic out of nowhere
the deranged dude reportedly had a fake
gun with the real knife stowed inside
i'll let joey explain what that looks
like thankfully chappelle is okay but
the assailant was not looking so hard he
left with a dangling broken arm plus
he's charged with assault with the
deadly weapon fellow comic chris rock of
all people hugging and spell at the live
show after the attack and joking was
that will smith which i thought was a
riot so what about the weapon first of
all
from just the way it was described at
this table during the commercial break
it sounds like a switchblade like a
novelty right looks like a gun you hit a
button a knife comes out and now you've
got a gun as a handle
it's a weapon if that's what it was and
that's what he came at him with that's
assault with the deadly weapon yeah if
it's a sharpie not to hurt him yeah you
know i think everyone's going to
reevaluate what security looks like they
probably should have after the oscars
which is unfortunate because we get to
go to these improv scenarios where we
get to sit real close to the stage and
hear a comic make fun of every one of us
including themselves and uh that may go
away with stuff like this you know
is it possible that this one person puts
that idea in a million people's minds
they never thought about it before i
already got the idea
but do people feel empowered because
this happened in california and what
will be the charges levity against him
will it be able to be is he already back
on the street kind of thing great
question i should have checked that
a copycat well yeah and they almost
predicted that there would be copycat
situations my question is how did you
get a knife through security uh and
there's a problem there but you know
what i liked about this i liked the fact
that everybody immediately understood
what it was it's like there's precedent
we saw what happened with will smith
we're not going to tolerate it we're
going on stage we're going to stop this
guy and yeah he was injured the attacker
was injured his elbow was going in the
wrong direction if you could see it
that's injured uh yeah that's injured
you know what that's what you get
is that dana what you get well i'm
actually really mad on behalf of daesh i
know you guys are too i
so
this attacker is going to get charged
with assault with a deadly weapon but
hollywood remember we did this show here
and everyone's like defending
uh will smith
and i'm like wait so he has the
privilege of celebrity yeah and so he
doesn't have any consequences which
makes the copycat much more likely and
what all these jack
jerks have done
has basically you're do you want to
watch dave chappelle at a live show
behind glass
because that's where it's headed yeah
and
now you're gonna have to have a
situation where
these guys who get up there performing
gals whoever they might be they have to
be fearful yeah i i i could never do
stand-up comedy but i imagine that
you're
all of your nerves and emotions are
already hyped and you have to add fear a
lot of fear on top of that and you're
watching to see who might be who it
might be i think that the decision by
the oscars to not charge about the
police to not charge will smith was it
was a problem it was will smith's
decision
i'm sorry chris rockefeller
live shows nope
i do live shows but i don't do stand-up
yeah at your live shows do you have
security no i don't do that geraldo i
don't do stand up
what's your question the question is do
you have security or do you yes fear
that you will yes the irony here is
chappelle says let's hear it for hip hop
and it was a rapper who rushes the stage
that guy wrote a song called chappelle
which he put out i guess in spotify a
couple years ago when he was going to
see chappelle and then that uh show got
cancelled because of
the pandemic um
hiding a
a real knife and a fake gun is very
interesting to me usually you hide the
weapon in something innocuous like a
carved out bible but his arm was i mean
he paid for it his arm looked like an
anti-am pretzel and uh it just shows you
though how vulnerable performers can be
this was at a netflix special they
confiscated phones but this guy got
through with a weapon and if that weapon
was actually a usable gun chappelle
could have been killed
you know and then of course the view
blamed trump on this which was great
how do you blame trump i have a lack of
civility can you believe that geraldo
see
see he wonders why hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else